W
FOR THIS EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW.
DMITRI PESKOV, WELCOME TO THE
PROGRAM.
CAN I START BY ASKING YOU, YOU
KNOW, AS I SAID, NEARLY FOUR
WEEKS INTO THIS WAR.
YOU BY ALL INTELLIGENCE, I
GUESS, YOU KNOW, EXPERTS, ARE
SOMEWHAT STALLED CERTAINLY
AROUND KYIV AND IN OTHER PARTS.
THERE SEEMS TO BE LOW MORALE
AMONG YOUR TROOPS.
THERE SEEMS TO BE EQUIPMENT
BREAKDOWNS AND COMMAND AND
CONTROL ISSUES.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS WHAT DOES
PRESIDENT PUTIN THINK HE HAS
ACHIEVED IN UKRAINE TO DATE?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, NOT YET.
HE HASN'T ACHIEVED YET, AND
WE'RE SPEAKING ABOUT SPECIAL
MILITARY OPERATION THAT IS GOING
ON, AND IT IS GOING ON STRICTLY
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE PLANS,
AND THERE WERE PURPOSES.
THEY WERE ESTABLISHED
BEFOREHAND.
OF COURSE, FIRST, I THINK WE
HAVE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE REASONS
FOR THIS OPERATION.
I MEAN, BECAUSE SPEAKING ABOUT
THE MORALE AGAINST -- IN --
AMONG OUR MILITARY.
OF COURSE, YOU OPERATE DATA AND
INFORMATION COMING FROM
DIFFERENT MEDIA AND FROM YOUR
INTELLIGENCE.
BUT YOU WOULD PROBABLY HAVE TO
DOUBT THIS INFORMATION.
YOU HAVE TO DOUBT IT, AND YOU
HAVE TO THINK TWICE WHETHER IT
IS TRUE OR NOT.
>> WELL, HERE'S THE THING, MR.
DMITRI PESKOV.
INTELLIGENCE THAT PREDICTED THE
INVASION TURNED OUT TO BE TRUE
DESPITE WHAT YOU TOLD US FROM
THE KREMLIN.
LET'S GET PAST THAT.
WE'VE ALSO HEARD CIVILIANS AND
JOURNALISTS WHO HAVE SEEN
RUSSIAN TROOPS AND WHO HAVE
RECOUNTED, BUT THAT'S -- BE THAT
AS IT MAY, WHEN YOU SAY HE
HASN'T ACHIEVED -- PRESIDENT
PUTIN HASN'T ACHIEVED YET, WHAT
DO YOU FORESEE?
BECAUSE THIS WAS GOING TO BE
ACCORDING TO YOUR OWN SIDE, AND
IN THE PRESS, IN THE STATE
SPONSORED MEDIA IN RUSSIA, A
PRETTY QUICK OPERATION.
IT WAS EVEN SUGGESTED THAT
WITHIN A COUPLE OF DAYS THAT
QUOTE, UNQUOTE, UKRAINE WOULD
RETURN TO, QUOTE, UNQUOTE,
MOTHER RUSSIA.
WHAT HAS GONE WRONG AND WHAT DO
YOU SEE FOR THE NEXT PHASE OF
THIS?
>> WELL, OF COURSE, NO ONE WOULD
THINK FROM THE VERY BEGINNING
ABOUT A COUPLE OF DAYS.
IT'S A SERIOUS OPERATION WITH
SERIOUS PURPOSES.
AND I THINK IF WE TRY TO
REMEMBER THOSE PURPOSES, THOSE
MAIN GOALS OF THE OPERATION,
IT'S TO GET RID OF THE MILITARY
POTENTIAL OF UKRAINE, AND THIS
IS WHY OUR MILITARY ARE
TARGETING ONLY MILITARY OBJECTS
ON THE TERRITORY OF UKRAINE.
NOT CIVIL ONES.
RUSSIAN MILITARY ARE NOT HITTING
CIVIL AIMS, CIVIL TARGETS.
NUMBER TWO, IS TO ENSURE THAT
UKRAINE CHANGES FROM ENTIRE
RUSSIAN CENTER TO A NEUTRAL
COUNTRY.
AND IN THIS SENSE, LET'S
REMEMBER THAT AFTER THE COLLAPSE
OF THE SOVIET UNION, THE NEUTRAL
STATUS WITH US FIXED IN THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE OF
THE COUNTRY.
THREE, TO GET RID OF THE
NATIONALIST BATTALIONS AND
REGIMENS WHO ARE OPPOSING
RUSSIAN TROOPS, WHO ARE NOW
TRYING TO COVER THEMSELVES UNDER
THE SHIELD OF CIVILIANS.
THUS, PAVING A WAY FOR CIVIL
CASUALTIES.
>> DMITRI --
>> I BEG YOUR PARDON.
IF YOU LET ME, AND ALSO TO
ENSURE, TO ENSURE THAT UKRAINE
ACKNOWLEDGES THE FACT THAT
CRIMEA IS ALSO AN UNTAKABLE PART
OF RUSSIA, AND THAT PEOPLE'S
REPUBLICS OF LUHANSK AND DONETSK
ARE INDEPENDENT STATES.
UKRAINE HAS LOST THEM AFTER THE
COUP THAT HAPPENED IN 2014.
>> OKAY.
SO BASICALLY YOU ARE PUTTING AND
LAYING OUT THE ORIGINAL DEMANDS
FROM PRESIDENT PUTIN WHICH I
UNDERSTAND SEEMED NOT TO HAVE
CHANGED.
LET US TALK ABOUT CIVILIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
LOOK, I KNOW YOU GUYS SAY THAT
YOU'RE NOT TARGETING CIVILIANS,
AND YOU'VE JUST TOLD ME IT WAS A
SPECIAL MILITARY OPERATION WHICH
IS I KNOW WHAT THE KREMLIN
MILITARY CENSORSHIP DEMANDS.
IT IS A WAR AND INVASION.
WE ARE WATCHING IT ALL OVER
GLOBAL TELEVISION NO MATTER WHAT
YOU TELL YOUR OWN PEOPLE.
THERE ARE SO MANY CIVILIAN
TARGETS, THAT IT'S HARD TO COUNT
THEM RIGHT NOW.
AND YOU KNOW, YOU MAY DENY IT,
BUT EVEN THE CHINESE, DMITRI,
EVEN THE CHINESE WHO ARE YOUR
FRIENDS HAVE EXPRESSED A VERY,
VERY DEEP CONCERN ABOUT CIVILIAN
TARGETS.
LET ME JUST READ WHAT THE
FOREIGN MINISTRY HAS SAID.
IT IS DEEPLY GRIEVED TO SEE THE
CONFLICT BETWEEN UKRAINE AND
RUSSIA AND HIGHLY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE DAMAGE DONE TO
CIVILIANS.
THEY ARE VERY, VERY CONCERNED.
THOSE ARE YOUR FRIENDS, THE
CHINESE.
NOT WEIRDO JOURNALISTS OR
ANYBODY WHO IS ACTUALLY WATCHING
IT WITH THEIR OWN EYES AND CAN
TELL THE TRUTH.
SO WHAT -- THE REAL QUESTION IS,
WHAT IS PRESIDENT PUTIN'S
STRATEGIC GOAL IN BLASTING THE
CIVILIAN INFRASTRUCTURE OF
PLACES LIKE MARIUPOL WHICH WE
ARE WATCHING TURN TO SMITHERINES
FOR THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS NOW.
WHAT'S THE STRATEGIC GOAL?
>> THE STRATEGIC GOAL IS TO
CLEAR UP THE MARIUPOL FROM
NATIONALISTIC REGIMENS WHO ARE
THERE IN A HEAVILY-COVERED
ENVIRONMENT, AND SO -- BY THE
WAY, THEY'RE SIMPLY NOT LETTING
PEOPLE OUT FROM THIS THING, FROM
THE TOWN.
AND THIS IS A PROBLEM.
BECAUSE NOW WE'RE RECEIVING LOTS
OF REFUGEES COMING FROM THERE,
AND THEY SIMPLY TELL US.
THEY'RE EYEWITNESSS.
THEY SIMPLY TELL US THAT THEY
WERE USED LIKE A SHIELD.
THEY WERE USED UNDER HEAVY
BOMBARDMENT, AND THEN THOSE
NATIONALISTS, THEY WERE -- THEY
WERE KILLING PEOPLE WHO WOULD
WANT TO LEAVE THE CITY.
AND NOW THE MAIN GOAL IS TO GET
RID OF THOSE BAD GUYS THERE.
>> DMITRI, WE ALSO HAVE
REPORTERS WHO ARE QUITE CLOSE TO
MARIUPOL, AND THEY ARE WATCHING.
THERE'S ACTUALLY SOME CIVILIANS
GETTING OUT RIGHT NOW.
THEY TELL A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
STORY, THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED FROM GETTING OUT, AND
WE KNOW THAT ANY ATTEMPT TO
ESTABLISH ANY KIND OF
HUMANITARIAN CORRIDOR HAS
COLLAPSED UNDER THE WEIGHT OF
RUSSIAN SHELLING, EVEN WHEN YOU
GIVE ASSURANCES.
THERE IS NO GOOD GOING IN, AND
YOUR OWN DEFENSE MINISTRY SAID
THESE LAST FEW DAYS THAT ONLY IF
MARIUPOL SURRENDERS WILL THEY
ALLOW FOOD, WATER, MEDICINE TO
GO IN THERE.
I HAVE -- I HAVE COVERED A
SIEGE.
PROBABLY THE LONGEST IN MODERN
HISTORY, THE SIEGE OFFER IS YA
ROW IS.
I KNOW THE PLAY BOOK VERY WELL.
THE QUESTION IS WHY ARE THEY,
THEN, COMING OUT AND TELLING US
THAT?
BUT ALSO, THERE ARE REPORTS THAT
RUSSIA IS TAKING CIVILIANS AND
CITIZENS FROM MARIUPOL, TAKING
THEM OVER TO RUSSIA, AND IN SOME
CASES, PUTTING THEM WAY OUT IN
THE HINTERLANDS AND TO WORK, AND
PERHAPS WORK CAMPS, I DON'T
KNOW, BUT PUTTING THEM TO WORK.
>> NO, THIS IS NOT TRUE.
THIS IS NOT TRUE.
IT'S A FAKE.
AND THEN BELIEVE ME, WE'RE ALL
LIVING NOT UNDER -- NOT ONLY
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES OF
MILITARY OPERATION.
WE'RE LIVING IN A SEVERE
INFORMATIONAL WAR.
A WAR OF FAKES.
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO KNOW THE
SITUATION FROM THE INSIDE.
AND SOMETIMES IT'S VERY HARD TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS GOING ON
THERE.
SO IF YOU ARE A JOURNALIST.
AND WE'RE RECEIVING A OPERATION
FROM OUR MILITARY INFORMATION,
AND THEN WE KNOW WHAT IS BEING
SAID BY THE PEOP